hello in this video i explain
what multipolarity is and how you
can check it online and do states
like
multi core linearity means that two
or more independent variables
correlate strongly with each other
the problem with multipolarity is that
the effect of individual variables is not
clearly separated  can
we have a look at the
recession equation again for this can we have
the dependent variable here and here
we have the independent variables such
as a high correlation between
x1 and x2 or if these two
variables are almost the same then it is
difficult to have b1 and  to determine b2
, for example, both are completely the same
knows that recession model should not be how
big and b1 and b2
the reaction model then becomes unstable
in mathematics one then speaks of
an over certain performance system
one wants to use the government model for a
prediction it doesn't matter  if
multi colina ried was available  gt in the case of a
prediction, one is only interested in how good
the prediction is, one is not interested in
what influence which
variable has on the dependent
variable, however, the reaction model
is used and measuring the influence of the
independent variable on the dependent
variable must not be multi-core
linearity  available then they are
available the coefficients cannot be meaningfully
interpreted
how can you now
diagnose multipolarity let's look again at
the regional line can then we
have the variable x1 x2 a little swing
ska we now want to know whether x1 is quite
identical to any other
variable or  a
combination of the other variables for
this we set up a new
recession model in this new
recession model we take x1 as the new
dependent variable if we can
now very
well infer x1 with the other independent variables, it means
that we are making the same statement  we
can hit with x1 can also hit with the other
variables therefore x1 is
more or less superfluous and
may make the recession model
unstable
if you can e.g. put together x1 completely from the other
variables
then the regression model cannot know
what b1 is or what  the other
coefficients should be then
our equation system would be determined via
this we can now do for all other
variables so we estimate x2
depending on the other variables
and we estimate xk depending on
each of the other variables now
we can model for all new recessions  in
this case recession models calculate the
so-called tolerance and the
value the tolerance results from
1 - the certainty requirement of
the
variance explanation again as a reminder the variance explanation indicates how much of the
variance of x1 can be explained by the other
variables all the more that is  the sooner
one speaks naturally  i talk about multipolarity
because we actually want
each individual variable to have as little
to do with others as possible if the
tolerance is below 0.1 you have to be
careful and it could be multipolarity
on the other hand we still have the
value the value is calculated by  1
due to the tolerance accordingly you have to
be careful if this value is greater than
ten so and now i will show you
how you can easily
check this requirement online here for visitors
day.de and click on the statistics
calculator if
you want to use your own
data  simply on the table
teacher
i use the at plays we
want to calculate a regression so
let’s just click on regression
let’s just take
the income as the dependent variable and
the age and weight of a person as the independent variable
now we see the results below
but we want to check the prerequisites
, so we click  just
check for prerequisites here
first we see the prerequisite
that linearity must be present here
you can see the results for your
variables you can see whether age has
a linear relationship with
income and whether weight has a linear
relationship with income
also see  you here whether the error
component is normally distributed for this it is
best to take a look on the golf course
then you will see the results for the
multipolarity in this table you can see
the tolerance and the value as I said
the tolerance should ideally be above 0.0 1 1
or the value  less than 10
and here the heterogeneity is
checked in this there you can see his
forecast plotted against the residency
here there should be a constant variance over the entire
range what we have not yet considered in
this tutorial about the recession
are
the variables dummy variables must  you
use when you have categorical variables
with more than two a  want to use expressions as
independent variables,
so let's continue with my
video about dummy variables, see you soon